oh my god I'm gonna make something
besides piss God it's my body even gonna
be able to drink this not piss well I
don't know about this whole disinfected
water I'll pair it on enough to
keep on drinking my own piss til the end
of my days the only thing I know that's
safe cuz I made it right out of my body
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now in
this episode I'm gonna be doing probably
the dumbest thing I've ever done in all
of subnautica and something I'm not
looking forward to very much but it all
has to do with this comment by chili
Matthew here who gave me a whole bunch
of good ideas but one of them above all
else and it seems plausible because a
lot of these are really good ideas but
the thing says that if I offer a reaper
a freshly caught peeper it will
delicately take it off you and leave
only works with peepers now I know that
stalkers like peepers and you can even
tame a stalker with peepers if you
really try I don't think it's gonna work
with a Reaper but I'm gonna try it
that'll come later then deep dusa says
remember to turn off the power in your
Cyclops when you're not using it so it
doesn't go dead I have forgotten to turn
off the power and I have not visited it
in a while I imagine it's dead and then
SN gaming who said that I should name
the new ship err ass you know bubble
butt err ass that's funny you guys
pointed out something very important
I've also beefed up the shrine pretty
incredibly and I've put a nice basic
double bed here so that you know just in
case when I fall asleep one night I wake
up and maybe just maybe I'll have a
friend next to me in my bed then I can
wake up every morning and I can just go
to sleep and look at the look at the
shrine and remember how I lost my only
friend in all of subnautica oh there now
I can wake up to that side and be
reminded of the loss of not bubble but
this was bumble memorial for the wrong
ship which just goes to show I'm
but what I got to do before that
you may notice that there's a lot more
lockers and everything's been beefed up
that's because I've been farming like
crazy I've got my miscellaneous
there I've got quartz and LEDs copper
silver gold I've got miscellaneous
crystalline I've got titanium
out the wazoo over here I've got so much
crap
why is my inventory full of piss wait
did I leave my game open and just start
pissing myself endlessly have I been
dying over
I did this farming I thought I paused
the game before what maybe um okay
guess I've just been pissing myself and
dying for the entire time
oh yeah and I did record while I was
farming so here's a little summary of
what you missed when I was doing that
I'd rather not be here ring around the
rosy pocket full of posy I'm going in a
butt hole and you're gonna go screw
yourself but sure would suck there's
more blowies in here I'm by blowies I
mean though I mean by this big though
there was not a mineral deposit
yeah you got a bunch of spiders in your
house and the only option is to burn the
whole goddamn house down you can't do
that with the ocean it's immune you
can't burn it with Thor's yep pretty
much just me screaming to the void so
before we get started on the actual
thing that we got to do I gotta do
something but all this piss I could just
I got a drink it's going horribly wrong
here give me you I need food real bad
and I need a peeper just for future
stupidity they love me all right hang on
gonna wash down all this piss with a
nice fish oh god I like going to a own
to a pub and ordering my favorite food
fishing kiss one of you peepers is gonna
help me in my quest to get myself
murdered which is probably gonna happen
a lot sooner than I thought it might but
all that aside it's all good Oh what is
going on in there what was that red ah
yep
see yeah there's even a big arrow you
big dumb idiot
turn off your goddamn engine you piece
of poop and then I don't do that cuz I'm
done it's all good it's fine it's fine
it's all fine I'm gonna cook me up some
grub and it's all fine don't yell um
okay
let me put the excess peepers that I got
and no all right now I'm good I kiss
everybody papers okay well I just shoved
those in my gob as hard as I could
all right so what I'm going to do next
is I am going to what am I gonna do I'm
gonna be able to bunch more solar panels
and then eventually I will make a
thermal plant and use enough power
transmitters to be able to get that
power all to my base but that's for
another episode I don't think I'm gonna
be able to get to that today so I'm
just gonna focus on improvements of my
current situation and if I can improve
my current situation then I'm gonna be a
lot happier in my circumstance so I'm
gonna take this copper I'm gonna build
up load more solar panels because that's
how eco-friendly I is and also these
kind of increase my battery bank so it's
good it's good it's all fun and
Przewalski's oh yeah oh yeah
now don't matter where the Sun likes to
hide I got all the power I need I didn't
cheat at all you guys saw you guys saw
for realsies
Oh any more titanium coming yeah yes yes
look at me
look at this look at this
seeing this you see how awesome I am
seeing that that's sorry about my
spit just so exciting okay that'll be
where the moon pool is so I need like an
observation deck here oh yeah let's get
this oh yeah yeah that's buried penis
like yeah I've got myself a scanner oven
a lot lower integrity than I once had
but hey it's me we're talking about I
didn't have integrity to begin with so
I'm assuming you're gonna connect
automatically and if you don't know how
to punch you in the dick
there we go that's a good tune that you
do good all right all right all right
scooby-doo pop that ladder hell yeah
hell yeah look I got like a real room
going on out look at this oh look at
this look at all the blink Blanc's oh
hell yeah okay so I got that let's pump
the seamoth back into the bad boy and
let's see how she do all right screw
delije dude - did Lily stock her past
well can be Bjorn killed him Oh systems
online so we had father but we had
bumble but we've also got a share but to
be perfectly honest that uh I'm not a
person to convinced about that one I
mean it's fine and all I guess but it's
fine I suppose
and I've got this I actually had an
extra one of these surprisingly so at
least it'll give me some depth out of
this thing and it won't be completely
stupid
all right crush step now 300 yeah
looking diet a deeper level yeah okay so
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go do the
dumb thing that I said I was gonna do
I'm gonna get it I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go do the incredibly dumb thing that I
said I was gonna do I'm gonna dump any
of this just in case but gonna bring me
a paper um I have a paper right right
there put you right there all right okay
all right this is not gonna go well save
right now is not gonna go well I can't
probably if it doesn't go well I'm
probably not gonna respond the same but
things gotta go the way it was
suggesting so everybody blame Chile
Matthew if this don't work right cuz I
don't see how a Reaper
leviathans gonna gingerly take this
don't like it they like it
I haven't charged a Reaper Leviathan on
foot in a long time and this is a bad
idea
yeah is that the sound of it
uh okay all right well there's somewhere
around here I just I'm so scared who
wants a big pertinently do was it look
like death
dark dark death there by hello you own a
paper
you took the paper and took the paper
hey did the paper into the paper the
paper and get the paper
it took the paper I might throw up I
don't feel good the paper took the paper
ok I'm back in big bucks Barry because I
need to get these things off the wall
but man oh wow oh boy oh I got an
advanced wiring kit Wow good for me oh
my god I don't feel good I feel I might
throw legitimately
I might throw up oh my god man oh hey
this - there's two more slots here so
that's good maybe there's more upgrades
to be made for the Cyclops I think
there's yeah what other upgrades can I
get fire suppression system hey that's
probably pretty good decoy to upgrade
all right huh
I don't like that so with that being
said and that new knowledge gained I
know what I should do
I gotta go find I gotta go find I gotta
go find Bubble Boy
now I know bubble butts probably broken
and dead
but if bubble butt is still out there
then that means you know like like out
there as in you know bubble bot is in
pieces but those pieces can be used and
maybe the modules are there I I mean I
can't be certain but you know I'll never
be I'll never be okay if I don't
actually go and see for myself I'll
always wonder you know always be like
man did I not do enough maybe bubble but
still alive out there like I don't know
I just need some kind of closure so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna find out and because
I've got this peeper trick then maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe baby maybe I
don't know but maybe so that's got to be
the next thing that I do right that's
just that's what I got to do so I'm
gonna go off I'm not even gonna take big
bucks Barry
cuz I don't have the power I guess while
I'm gone before I do that I should take
the the power of things and I should
turn off the engine I should turn it off
oh yeah yeah I should do that yeah okay
alright I'm gonna plug these pleas in
it's gonna suck the power right out of
that but daylight's coming so hopefully
daylight's coming I got some peepers I
got cut so much piss I am Chu Chu on the
train to hell bill I'm in the vicinity
I'm in the vicinity I why can't I see
right now I hate this I hate this I
hate this I hate I know this trick works
but for some reason I I'm willing to
believe that there's only like a 50/50
shot of it actually working in the right
hey I got a paper I got a paper I got a
paper I got a paper I got a paper I got
a paper I got a paper hey you want a
paper you want a baby buddy you want a
paper
I got a beeper for you I got a paper for
you okay I'm gonna go down you ignore me
okay anybody see a bubble butt around
here anybody see pieces nothing like
that okay
all right nobody sees pieces nobody sees
Reese's Pieces goddamn give me a break
here Oh give me a break here hit me in
the face with those that's the question
right cuz there has to be a record there
would be even if it like fell down to
the bottom rolled around it would still
exist at some point right oh man there's
magnetite okay that's good found
magnetite
I do need that that's good okay got that
oh hey war pea whoo that's just normal
wreckage I think anyway or just say time
capsule whoa what the hell whoa
huh Oh beacon
hey gimme you ass get out of here
get out of there get out of here you
it wouldn't have just vanished it
wouldn't have that's not how it works
when it breaks if it breaks like it
breaks into pieces that's the thing oh
hey huh you want to be everything
everything I hate it I know Karen I have
a where okay all right I got a BP I got
a PB you're falling into pieces he
couldn't have carried it that far
what's that he said no come on you were
thought oh you were something are you
what is this
oh my best buy sell buy Wow
an alien vents this is the era you son
of a 10-day downloads for the aliens
vent okay all right alien vent yeah
that's right it's that's what's leading
to these sea Emperor's chambers where'd
you put bubble butt would you put him
terrifying terrifying horrible horrible
horrible horrible horrible horrible
another I got another I just so happen
to have more I'm out I'm out this is a
bad idea there's a bad idea bad idea I'm
running out of paper whoa whoa whoa hey
hi Oh howdy neighbor
how you doing um could you not fly that
close to my base that is not okay
ah all right we're back we're back we're
back we're back we're back from that
horrible horrible adventure why did I do
that why why why why did I do that I do
not know okay let's make a computer chip
why why why I'm gonna build the vehicle
upgrade pay and look at these these bad
boys are so full of power and take that
gonna build it what do I need for a
computer chip I need table coral that's
just it all right and then that's what I
won't go good so I'll be right back
all right people go up great station bum
boom baby boom baby boom baby boom so I
know what I need to do I need to get the
materials to be able to build some more
efficiency things the depth module I
need to do that in the modification
station I got back in the Cyclops but
before I do any of that it is time to
name this new thing and I think before I
do that I have to get the color right
you know I I just have to get the color
wait hang on let's get a look at her oh
she's beautiful
oh she's beautiful I'm a caller I take
that as a greement Karen oh you're just
saying you could eat bubblegum up Karen
that's so cute oh that's so cute
well everybody say hi to bubblegum that
back lettering is not showing up as
bright as I want it to come on
where's the brightness where's the
bright bright give it a bright bright I
guess that's gonna have to do all right
everybody say hi to bubblegum now
bubblegum and I are gonna go on a lot of
adventures and I'm gonna take care of
you bubblegum don't worry and don't
worry about what happened to bumble butt
and bubble bubble for you but bubblegum
we're gonna go places so thank you
everybody so much for watching everybody
say hi to bubblegum here let me know
anything down in the comments below and
if you have any advice and/or jokes to
make it my expense let me know as well
put you on Walker so thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]